libya's warring forces are on the move
here soldiers of halifa koftas
Libyan National Army advance West there
at Brega now and hoping to open a new
front at cert for months they've been
fighting on the outskirts of Tripoli
against the army of the government of
national Accord on Thursday the UN
backed GNA announced its agreed to
receive greater military help from
Turkey after after and his unlawful site
is receiving support from whom this is
not - all while suraj with his lawful
and legitimate government i'm not
receiving any support currently by
standing by his side and provide them
with the assistance we can afford this
is a proxy conflict that splits the
Middle East in North Africa and beyond
the UAE Saudi Arabia Egypt and Russia
have all given greater or lesser
assistance to hafta but the fear
half-done might topple the government of
national Accord has spurred turkey into
over to action for turkey their interest
is not Libya itself anybody who looks at
the map of the Mediterranean will see
that Egypt to Turkey South South Cyprus
Greece and potentially Libya if it falls
under after and therefore goes into the
UAE orbit is forming a sort of maritime
choke hold on to turkey four Turkey
Libya is the final chance to prevent
this chokehold from taking place
although Libya's GNA has ratified the
security and military cooperation deal
it struck with Turkey last month it's
not immediately clear what kind of
military support turkey might offer
Libya or when but it reinforces Turkey's
role in influencing Libya's future like
with Syria Russia and Turkey have taken
different sides increasing their
diplomatic leverage and cooperation mook
stating we are here we Russia by the way
are in permanent contact with mr. surage
his government with marshal hafta we
continuously communicate with our
partners including those in Turkey in
Europe in other countries in our opinion
the best solution would be to find
compromise between the two sides of the
conflict at the UN al Jazeera asked the
secretary-general spokesman for his take
on Turkey's military assistance I think
the Secretary General a couple times
yesterday was very
clear in his expression of frankly of
its I would say his frustration at the
situation in Libya of the constant
flowering by various member states of
the arms embargo and and of the
continued fighting that we're seeing in
and around Tripoli in other places in
the country but that fighting certainly
isn't over yet war ii challenge al
jazeera